I have another hypothesis to throw in to
this discussion as well Brett which you
may have seen on my Twitter I keep
mentioning something called the
psychopathic determinants of health so
if we go further Upstream because what
we're trying to understand also is a
culture you know this is you know if the
medical profession aren't aren't dealing
with this in the way they should if
we're still trying to mandate coerce
kids to have the vaccine when we're
talking about it being suspended for
everybody how does one explain that and
my uh hypothesis which I think is based
upon evidence is at the root of the
problem if you go Upstream
is that we have very big powerful
corporations in this case big Pharma who
have had increasing power
over medical decision making over
probably the last couple of decades and
everything really starts from their
behavior so the entity that is the big
Corporation is there predominantly and I
think it's really important to have this
very explicit discussion with people I
tell it to my patients I said they are
there they have a legal or fiduciary
obligation to produce profit for
shareholders not to give you the best
treatment
but the real Scandal is that those who
have a duty to patience and scientific
Integrity Doctors Medical institutions
academic journals collude with industry
for financial gain but the way that the
pharmaceutical industry operates has
been described not by me
by a leader in his field forensic
psychologist Dr Robert Hare he actually
documents that the entity not the
individuals within them we're not we're
not pointing fingers at CEOs of
companies or anything like that but the
way that the drug industry operates is
essentially akin to a psychopath you can
compare it to Psychopathic Behavior so
callus this concern for the feelings of
others deceiving people for profit you
know these are typical behaviors that
there's a short record
um of course one great example I know we
mentioned it before we start the podcast
is around biox and what happened there
and actually if you look back and and
you understand that the you know Merck
new those scientists internal scientists
knew that it was going to cause an
increase in heart attacks but
it didn't it didn't bother them from the
company perspective because they knew
they were going to make a lot of money
so you know the only way to describe
this type of behavior in my view is
psychopathic so actually I think you
know maybe we need to change the
narrative in terms of explaining the
culture in many in in what's going on in
health right now as being a downstream
effect of an entity that behaves that is
anti-human that is anti-democratic that
suppresses free speech that suppresses
Freedom of Information and we can apply
all of that to what's happened during
the rollout of the code vaccine uh which
I again I um elaborate on in my paper
yeah I I resonate with a lot of that and
uh in some sense we've landed in my area
of specialty as an evolutionary
biologist I can tell you exactly what
happened which is our system of laws
surrounding corporate behavior is
basically a niche it describes a niche
and what has happened is that any
corporation that didn't start out
Psychopathic has evolved into and
effectively Psychopathic entity because
it couldn't compete otherwise and so it
really shouldn't be any surprise to us
at all that this is the kind of behavior
the shocking indifference is our failure
as human beings we extrapolate we over
extrapolate our own internal experience
and we project it onto these
corporations because of course when we
encounter them we encounter them in a
human form that's describing what
they're doing
but you know of course they're
Psychopaths right
um if they weren't they would have uh
failed in business so they evolved into
them
um and this does explain not only uh you
know vioxx but a basically General
systematic enlarging of loopholes I mean
effectively you've got an industry
that plays a particular game I call it
the Pharma game and you tell me if this
matches your understanding but the
Pharma game
involves owning various
pieces of intellectual property
finding conditions to which one of these
pieces of intellectual property can be
plausibly linked
broadening the diagnosable
characteristics so that the maximum
number of people are thought to have the
condition
applying these pieces of intellectual
property essentially Pharmaceuticals you
know compounds or treatments that are
highly profitable and then ignoring or
systematically obscuring any harms that
might emerge as a result I mean that's
the winning strategy and
one of my if you know there's it's very
easy to imagine
all sorts of conspiratorial things
happening in the case of covid the harms
are so shocking that one uh you know
struggles to imagine what the
conversations inside of Pharma sounded
like but
um the shallow end of the pool
sounds like this Pharma has captured our
governmental structures it corrupts them
365 days a year as a matter of Simply
doing business and when covet arrived
there was no mechanism for recognizing
it as anything different than a huge
business opportunity so it steered Us in
this direction because it's doing that
all the time over hundreds of different
compounds and conditions that's just
simply what it does that's what it is
absolutely I think that's summed up very
very well
um that's exactly what they do um their
incentive I I um debated at the
Cambridge Union a few years ago the CEO
of AstraZeneca and the motion that was
put forward is that that we need more
people taking more drugs that was
obviously the motion put forward by them
and I post it
and um of course that would be the ideal
scenario for them to get as many people
as possible on as many drugs as possible
and exploit their the legal entity that
they they function under
to be able to do that and I think if
we're going to combat this as well
ultimately
Brett it needs changes in the law you
know these laws themselves that allow
them to do this are clearly not
Democratic they're not just they're not
ethical
um and therefore
um what we need is really uh citizens to
become aware and of course you know one
of the ways of disseminating such
information is through mainstream media
and then it puts pressure on politicians
but to paraphrase Noam Chomsky
um you know the um doctors and patients
don't know what's happening and they
don't even know that they don't know
so the reason I mentioned that I'll give
you an example of
um ignorance of this problem these
structural failures at the very highest
level a couple of months ago I gave a
talk at one of the meetings organized
during the conference of the British
Medical Association I had um very senior
medical establishment figures there the
chairman of the British Medical
Association the president of the British
Medical Association
and in that talk I talked about the
corporate capture of medicine and public
health that was essentially the type
talk title
and during the talk I mentioned failure
of the regulator to do its job properly
and I said that the mhra in our country
the medical health and Regulatory agency
receives most of its funding 86 from the
pharmaceutical industry the chairman of
the VMA didn't believe it he was
gobsmacked you know he would he he
looked around and said is this true of
course you know ignorance of these
structural failures are even at the very
highest level Rachelle wolenski you
remember quite um you may remember her
commenting about the fact that her
optimism from the vaccine came from a
CNN news report so the media has a huge
role to play and I know from Paul
Thacker investigative journalist he did
a Blog on this that that original CNN
news report was reported on the
so-called efficacy of the vaccine was
almost verbatim a reproduction of
Pfizer's press release you really
couldn't make it up Brett you really
couldn't make it up so um the the I
think the understanding acceptance of
the these entities and how they function
is one thing but I think what people
need to realize is that The Regulators
themselves the people that are supposed
to be filtering this information and
you know uh protecting the public from
these so-called excesses and
manipulations of Industry are actually
themselves captured by industry
universities certainly in this country
over the last 20 to 30 years have more
and more funding from the drug industry
uh most of their funding for research
comes from the drug industry now they
are universities are supposed to be
Guardians of the truth and represent the
moral conscience of society but how can
they represent the moral conscience of
society when they are being influenced
and controlled by an immoral entity
what's going to happen it doesn't take a
rocket scientist to figure out that's
going to have a hugely negative impact
on society
yeah there's you know trying to do
anything about it without changing the
law is a little bit like taking the
water in your glass and trying to shove
it over to one side and the answer is no
no it's going to fill the glass that's
what it does and we've got a niche and
these entities are going to operate
within that Niche and become adapted to
it the only solution involves changing
the niche now of course
that is almost impossible to do because
frankly buying political influence in
the west is inexpensive when you're
making the kind of money that they're
making it's just the cost of doing
business and so you know my hope is that
the horror of what we've done
surrounding covid would wake people up
would embarrass them into having to
change laws even though there was a
financial incentive for not doing it but
so far I have not seen evidence of that
yeah bro I agree with you I think in in
some ways we have to we have to use this
crisis
uh and and turn it into an opportunity
for good
and I think I'm with you I think this
will be the Tipping Point I think that I
think we're not far off the bubble
bursting breath to be honest I think
more and more people are becoming aware
and
um and the more that they the more that
do they become you know advocates for
the movement to say this is not
acceptable and and we are angry about
this and we are going to hold people
accountable for this
and that movement is growing every day
Brett and it will reach a Tipping Point
I have no doubt but we obviously as
advocates for the truth uh we can't be
complacent we need to keep making noise
uh and of course I even this
conversation I'm sure in itself will
have its own ripple effect in helping
that change happen
it will uh I will point to I mean
obviously this is one of the messages of
your terrible story
um but the fact of
the injuries from these therapies being
so common means that many people are
going to be touched
quite directly this is not an abstract
question for an increasing number of
people I will say that even
in my friend group
I can I know off the top of my head two
other stories where people that I know
well enough to have shared a meal with
them have lost fathers
do I know for certain that this is what
happened I don't but the pattern is
awfully clear
and you know that's before we get to the
many uh very serious but lesser Adverse
Events of which I could list off
a couple dozen
um there it it's it's shocking how many
people are seeing the evidence in in
real time right in front of them in
their own families and friend groups so
that will have a a profound effect
[Music]
thank you